[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by my good pal Mr Ken Coleman this hour
and we're taking your calls at
88255 5225 you call in we'll talk about
your life your money your work the toxic
boss that job that you're really
dreaming of and how you can take steps
to get there and uh Ken this is this has
been a Hot Topic especially this year
with the hot job market people are going
I've got options yeah what do I do next
yeah I saw something this morning uh new
survey uh that came out that said 42% of
Americans are saying they're going to
demand a raise this year to keep keep up
with inflation is that how it works and
I just chuckled you know you know a good
chuckle it's not a true laugh it's a
chuckle like you can't these people
cannot demand a raise to keep up with
inflation because that's going to
actually create more problems involving
inflation and you've got so many
Americans can't even name the three
branches of government so I'm not
surprised if people quiz me Ken are
going to demand that their boss give
them a raise for a cost of living first
of all it does work that way or people
will be out of business and secondly
you're going to get laughed at and you
might get fired so see how that works
out for you we're here to help you with
things like that uh because the bottom
line is is if you're living debt-free
and even if you're in the robust zone of
gazelle
intensity you can be inflation proof
people who stand on that debt free stage
every day are inflation proof I'm
inflation proof you're inflation proof
is it because we're better than anybody
else no it's because we have margin and
we have peace so uh you know what we
live in a Topsy Turvy time so yes we'll
talk about your work as well because as
David said it's your greatest wealth
building tool your income tied to your
work and uh so we'll help you we'll help
you uh in that process however we can
because it's tied to money it's tied to
relationships and your overall health so
your quality how about that for a setup
I love it all right well give us a call
if you're interested in that pitch right
there
225 Angel kicks us off in Dallas Angel
welcome to the
show hi thanks so much for taking my
call sure George and Ken just my lucky
day I get to talk to Ken as well as you
George I love your show oh thank you wow
we should record that James and uh we'll
play that for our wives I did not pay
Angel anything to say those nice things
about us very nice I always love every
drink that you suggest on Smart happy
hour oh thank you for listening I wish
Rachel was here to hear this instead of
Ken yeah well she needs the
validation my question really is
probably um geared more toward you my
husband is
42 and I am 50 we have two children and
one uh is going off to college in June
and then we will have one child left in
high school we make about
$335,000 each year um he would like to
retire when our uh youngest uh graduates
high school in three years so at
45 because he's been in the job that in
financial services for 22 years since he
graduated college but it's not very
fulfilling uh but you know I I just
don't know if that's the right time to
retire at 45 we don't have any debt um
our house is worth 83
it's paid off wow Cong and we have about
1.3 million in retirement
savings so I would like to encourage him
to yes change careers I just don't know
when the right time is financially for
that to happen well that's a very
interesting question uh coming from you
and I think that your your safety gland
is probably flaring a little bit is that
fair yes it well let me just tell you as
a objective bystander here um it
shouldn't be you guys are fine um this
is not a man who is a lazy loafer it's
not a man who's confused he's not having
a midlife crisis I think this is a guy
I'm taking a stab here tell me if I'm
right or wrong that has done the same
thing since he got out of college he's
done quite well at it you guys have a
lot of margin and at the age of 45
because he has less pressure he wants to
shift sh he wants to Pivot and you
should be totally in support of that cuz
I don't think this guy is going to just
shut it down for the rest of his life I
think he's going to move on to something
even more exciting and might even move
on to something more uh profitable
financially so I think this is a good
move because of your position you guys
have no debt in the world a fat
retirement and I think him stepping away
and reassessing uh as this season comes
to an end when your youngest goes off to
college I think it's a great decision
because he wants to do it and he can do
it therefore I'm fine with
it awesome how do you feel now what are
your fears around that angel is it is it
Financial or is it I don't know what
he's goingon to do he's not even halfway
through his life he's gonna sit there
all day is that
it uh I just think he doesn't know what
he wants to do and even though um he
would like to leave he's feeling those
golden handcuffs and thinking if I leave
will we have you know be able to provide
health care for the children and
sometimes kids come back and I'm
thinking we could just sell this house
and have a smaller house but he would
like to move into an apartment and not
own anything so and you're like wait a
second Sparky that's my Nest you're
talking about and you want to keep your
mcmansion and have your nice life I see
what's going on okay couple things angel
number one he's got three years if I
heard you correctly he's got three years
to figure this out that's plenty of
time and he's got three years to do it
under no pressure at all that's even
better so I'm going to give you my get
clear career assessment for your husband
okay Chris is going to give that to you
as my gift I'm also going to give him
the book uh from paycheck to purpose
which outlines the seven stages to
moving
into the real dream job not a fantasy
but something that he absolutely loves
and something that matters to him it's
doable he's got three years to figure
this out that's more than enough time
and he has all the clues all the details
that he needs he's been doing good work
for a long time and so he's going to
retire to something not from
something and I think if I were to say
to him today hey uh I can guarantee you
that we can get you into something at 45
that you really really enjoy that lights
your heart up and you can make really
good money and never even miss the old
job what do you think he would say to me
he would say sign me up okay so we are
signing him up so it starts with the
assessment in the book from paycheck to
purpose and and from there he's got
everything he needs to to go and explore
and make connections and figure out that
thing that he wants to do you got it got
it and that means you get to keep the
mcmansion woo that's a big piece of this
puzzle they are not in agreement on what
kind of Life they want to have going
forward that's the bigger piece of this
we can figure out the finances you can
go make more money but I I like where
this is going we have some homework to
do but I think they're on the path to
being financially independent I think I
think once he figures out that thing
he'll cave on the apartment thing I
think that's an extreme reaction to a
guy who's just tired of being in the
hamster wheel amen thanks for the call
Angel this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're buying a home in today's
market it takes more than hope and an
internet search you need a team that you
can trust through thick and thin that's
why I've recommended Churchill Mortgage
for 30 years the experts at Church Hill
know their stuff and they'll take care
of you the ramsy way that's why
Churchill is the only ramsy trusted
mortgage company go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn more
Churchill mortgage.com
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ramsey
personality Ken Coleman the number to
call if you want to jump into the
conversation is
5225 and we'll be here for you I know
it's scary to use that phone app on your
phone instead of whatever else the kids
are using it for but it's the only way
currently to get advice on the show I
get a lot of DMS on Instagram saying hey
can you help me I say call the show
don't be scared we're here yeah I love
the DMS but it it's very hard to answer
these complex question via DMS yeah
Ken's got to get his readers on it's a
whole situation I can't type with my
thumbs like George can did you just tell
everybody that I use readers I don't
think anyone's shocked by that a lot of
people are most of the people in the
lobby think I'm about 35 had 2020 Vision
uh yeah you know it's fine you look
great in them Ken you got some stylish
ones not as good as you look in that
child siiz jean jacket I knew it was
coming I was waiting for an OSH Goos BOS
reference it's all I got it's all I no
it is a it's a wonderful Jean Jacky you
look great it looks like an adult small
that would be accurate is it it's not
extra small I have no idea okay you know
I I don't look at those things can it
just if it fits I sits there we go nice
I like that I do like that oh let's get
takes us off the air here we go
Kimberly's up next in San Diego Kimberly
save us from ourselves how can we
help hi George and Ken thank you so much
for taking my call sure bet you sound
like you're in a fantastic
mood I am I I am in a good mood good for
you that's exciting how can we help
thank you um so my question is about
investing um specifically for my twin
daughters and they're in a bit of a
unique situation they've filmed a
handful of commercials nice and they
yeah so they've earned a little bit of
money so I'm just looking um for some
advice on how to invest that how old are
your
daughters they're four how fun were they
just so stoked on
this yeah it's been pretty fun for them
was it print or uh
film
um so the first one they did was film um
and that was when they were babies they
were like two months old oh
wow yes they're experienced actresses by
this
point I guess so yeah um so the ones
this year they haven't come out yet so
we're not exactly sure how they're going
to be used um but they had two this year
that is so fun my daughter um actually
all three of my kids did some uh early
acting and my daughter has stayed with
it so how much money are we talking
about um it's not a lot um this year
it's about $5,000 each nice that's a lot
for a four-year-old I was gonna say a
four-year-old a $10 bill they think they
can retire I
know so 5K each that's awesome where is
it
now um so I was thinking it's just in
the bank but I was thinking uh of
investing in mutual funds for them um
just
because well I'm just not sure I want it
to be accessible for them when they're
18 so they can decide how they want to
use it um but then I was also wondering
since they do have earned income if I
should put some of it into rock for them
or if that's kind of silly to no that's
not silly at all it's one of the
greatest life hacks of all time and
because you have to have earned income
to contribute to a Roth IRA and so the
one caveat kind of loophole is if your
child does legitimate work like they
have done you can actually invest that
money and we talk about compound growth
on the show all the time if you let that
money just sit for 20 years 30 years 40
years I mean they're going to be multi-
multi-millionaires just from the work
they're doing today so you're thinking
the right
way okay and I love what Ken did for his
kids and the way they process this when
they get a check cuz it's a
four-year-old right so we it's a weird
thing to try to explain to this
four-year-old that they just got all
this money and what to do with it right
you're kind of the financial advisor
right now so what we did for Josie I
think she was seven when she uh did one
of her first paid ads it was a print ad
for like FIS I think like she had bread
sticks and something like this so anyway
she was old enough to understand like
I'm getting paid and I think she made
$1,500 you know which again fantastic
money she's seven and so we sat her down
and you know we understood that she
understood that she was getting you know
paid for doing this this this modeling
and this little acting job and so we uh
explained the concept of giving and uh
so we we pulled out a chunk and we let
her put it in the offering plate at
church that week right and then uh and
then we gave her some money to spend and
I think we gave her like a hundred bucks
or something which again you would have
thought I mean this kid's eyes bugged
out of her head it was like this is your
$100 you can put it in your little Bank
you know we had the Ramsay give save
spin little you know I don't know if we
still make this oh yeah I think they
just updated it actually yeah so she
could see it I think we gave it to her
in 520s because it just felt so awesome
for her and then we told her that we put
the rest in savings and we put it in her
529 account um that she could you know
use uh later as she goes into any kind
of training or any type of education so
that's what we did we just explained it
to her uh and again at the age of 7 and
she was able to understand it and and so
so four might be a little bit four is
probably a little early uh but let him
let him experience the fruits of their
Labor uh it was so exciting to Let Her
Go I mean I was like you can blow it
because it wasn't about being wise with
it she's seven it was she's already
being wise with the money was like go go
buy something fun I think she bought a
build-a bear and you know whatever
seven-year-old girls love to buy it was
just all a bunch of nothing she was
excited but it was it was the reward
piece that she got I work I get the
reward and then I've also been smart
with it and I saved it so we we were
very practical with it so whether or not
you want to do the Roth of the 529 I
think that's a great move but let them
spend some of it and then teach them to
give some of
it okay so about the Roth does that tie
it up until retirement for them now
technically in most cases the Roth
you're not going to be able to access
until 59 and a half you can take out the
contributions that you've put in uh
without penalty but even then I wouldn't
because you're unplugging that compound
growth that's building and the way your
kids are going to be set up they're not
going to need to dip into their
retirement accounts for money and so you
could do a few things I would put most
of it in that Roth IRA I think that's a
great move you could put a little a
little bit of it in a 529 into a high
yield savings account and just let that
money grow into kind of a custodial
account for them at the bank uh and then
like Ken said give a little bit of it
spend a little bit of it what's the toy
they've been wanting all right let's go
get them the toy you you worked hard for
this and that comes from work so uh I
would I would just say leaveing that
Roth they're going to thank you later
when you start doing the calculations on
$5,000 in a Roth IRA from Age 4 to
64 it will explode your brain it is
going to be so much money even if you
never added to it and so that's what I
love about that they're going to be like
Mom thank you for doing that because you
just made me a millionaire at 4 years
old and I didn't even know it that's
changing your family tra okay awesome
thank you so much absolutely thanks for
the call yeah you're good mom K mom of
the year kber how about that I can't
wait until your little princess comes to
you and says she wants to uh uh act or
maybe sing or write I need to ask you
about this Ken so those of you that
don't know I had a baby I didn't have a
baby my wife had a baby less than four
weeks ago we're coming up on four weeks
and I'm already thinking about the 529
and I don't want to push her towards
acting but it's one of those loopholes
where you can go if she can contribute
to that Roth at 2 months old that's a
game Cher for her future mhm so uh what
are your thoughts about that Ken pushing
your kid into something like do you kind
of encourage it let them explore their
passions obviously they're so so parents
don't push your kids into anything uh
that's the problem we've got with this
uh current generation they've been
pushed and they've been coddled and so
they've not had a chance to make their
own decisions so what you want is if
your little kid comes to you and says
hey Daddy I want to try soccer then go
great and sign them up for soccer if
they hate it two weeks in say you got to
finish the season oh teach them some
life lessons then if they come to you
say I want to try guitar say great and
go get them guitar lessons and if they
want to quit after two say no you got to
finish and you rinse and you repeat and
eventually they're going to do something
that makes the tuning fork of their
heart go off and now parents you've let
them Discover it and it's what they love
to do it's not reliving your childhood
dreams that you never met ouch beautiful
that's good advice this is the Ramsay
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level net week gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at nets.com
Ramsey that's nets.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camell joined by Ken Coleman if
you enjoy this show I imagine you would
enjoy some of the other shows on the
Ramsey Network including the Ken Coleman
show the George camel YouTube channel
smart money happy hour which I co-host
with Rachel Cruz we have a lot of fun on
that one very different style we don't
take calls it's just fun pop culture
comedy and real cocktails we had a
previous caller who said she Lov the
drink suggestions fun and we made one
live at smart conference a mocktail and
understand it was one of the best I've
had and I saw the recipe for that and uh
took a picture of my phone and I'm going
to do the real deal wow by the way an
honor uh is there any truth to the
rumors in the back of the Suburban when
we were riding back to the hotel you and
Rachel were promising
me that you would be a guest on Smart
money happy hours is this a bad time to
bring that up it's not as long as John
delone is not listening because he's
also wanting a coveted guest spot on
Smart money happy hour I see I don't
listen I don't pull the string scan I'm
not the producer okay we're just the
talent we're the mere talent but it
would be an honor to have you you guys
were talking a big game about how much
fun it would be for me to be on you add
a lot of value I think I would all right
we'll let America way people love to
blame their producers for when they
don't want to have on you know that's
true well you know the produc you should
have heard it in the back of the they
were laying it on thick hey you should
come on and blah blah blah blah blah but
uh I keep checking my inbox still
nothing nothing there keep dreaming okay
all right let's go to the phones if you
want to jump in the number to call is
8825 5225 we'll help you take the right
next step with your life your work and
of course your money Josh is in Albany
New York Josh welcome to the Ramsey show
how you doing hey folks thanks a ton for
taking the time to chat with me today I
appreciate hey uh so I find myself kind
of at a bit of a positive Financial
Crossroads in my life I just started a
new job um in Long Island that pays 125k
a year which is more than double my
previous salary it's great um but I
currently live in Albany New York so wow
I have been commuting down um and it's
about you know anywhere from 6 to 8
hours a day of driving depending on
traffic hold on a second how long have
you been commuting six to eight hours a
day it's only been two weeks and it is
on a hybrid schedule so I'm only in the
office two days at the moment so it's
not okay exceptionally brutal um and it
will probably be three days uh onsite
you know moving forward um and my
initial intention was to move down to
the city but the more I do the math the
more I think about it the more I'm
debating just doing the commute and
functionally doubling my already doubled
salary you know are you married kids
what's your status no single as the day
is long I don't even have a house plant
to worry about I think it's I think it's
bananas that you're even considering
doing this but the fact that you're
single is the only scenario yeah how old
are you by which I could do that uh 32
32 okay well I'll tell you it's not a
sustainable solution even two or three
days a week your mental health is going
to suffer you'll be calling the Dr John
deloney show uh shortly here because of
this so we've got to find a solution and
if that means finding a different job
finding a job that's closer that can pay
you that or moving to Long Island and
figuring it out maybe you get a roommate
for a while to uh be able to afford the
C idea why don't we why don't we get rid
of the extreme Josh and why don't we
think 30 miles 40 miles outside of Long
Island let's let's let's get outside a
little bit where maybe the cost of
living is not as much as being you know
right there where you work split the
difference uh good ways here
uh I just think you're going to
eventually get miserable you're going to
be miserable with all that and by the
way that's just not good for you and
your health um it's just not good for
you putting a lot of miles on your car
there's just a lot of diminishing
returns to this I'd really like to talk
you out of it okay so let's George is
the best at this all right so I'm I'm
gonna I'm gonna tap George here on the
shoulder tag team here let's talk him
through roommate let's walk through his
raise Plus cost of living let's walk
through this here's what happens Josh
people tend to go I've got a and b a is
I stay in Al a commute 8 hours or B I
moved to Long Island and broke and I go
what about CDE e f and you go down
through the alphabet here and so let's
talk through those scenarios could you
move closer to Long Island but not
directly in the city and have a half
hour commute 45 minute
commute yeah I mean I think if I'm going
anywhere even close to the city my
minimum commute is already going to be
like an hour you know even unless I can
find something explicitly like in the
township that I would be in but the cost
of living there is actually much higher
because it's kind of a rich area um so
I've been looking at like maybe pipy
something to cut it in half you know
maybe an hour and a half commute each
day so how much more is it how much more
does it cost you to live in
pipy uh by the way I love saying that
word I knew it I was just thinking Ken
loves just came out of my mouth and it
felt so good uh someone say it again
pipy
there it is there it is uh how much more
is it to live there than where you're
living now in
Albany well my current situation on
Albany my rent is 575 bucks a month
which I'm never going to live this cheap
again in my life are you in a
box no it's actually a great
apartment my room is like 400 square
feet it's gigantic um it's 400 feet is
never gigantic but but how much
difference whole apartment just my
bedroom oh your bedroom okay what's uh
what's the difference difference in
cost um probably I'm looking at a
minimum of at least $1,500 increase in
rent probably $2,000 in rent for a one
bedroom sounds about appropriate yeah
probably 15 to 2,000 somewhere in there
what about a
two-bedroom uh probably only a little
bit more maybe 2,200 okay so that's
where I'm going with this you get one
roommate a similar you know guy like you
in his 20s early 30s single and just
looking to have a place to crash that's
all you're looking for I got who's clean
who can pay on time now your rent is
1,00 bucks right but you also just gain
7 hours of your life back every single
day yeah and not to mention you just
doubled your salary
correct yeah more so more than that okay
so doubling your rent payment is not the
end of the world yeah it's not like
you're going backwards I think in your
mind you're so stuck on this
unbelievable rent that you have 500
bucks a month which is unbelievable it's
like you're in the Stone Age uh somehow
you've managed that that's phenomenal
good for you but you're looking at that
in the increase over that and you're not
looking at how much better your life is
this great job that you love uh you're
over double your salary I I think you
need to be focusing on that and this is
about stretching and growing and you can
you can handle a $1,500 a month one
bedroom that's not outrageous given the
money he's making yeah do you have any
debt uh just my car which is about
$32,000 but that's it how much do you
owe on
that uh on the car is it 32
yeah 32 oh what's it
worth um probably about that it's a 2022
subar R back I just bought it earlier
this year yeah but dude you are just
appreciating the snot out of that thing
with all that driving you're going to
put a 100,000 miles on that thing in a
year the way you're going that's the
number one reason to move is that right
there yeah that you're going to be
underwater on that car if you AR is
going to be screaming at you swearing at
you puffing I'd get you a Prius if
you're going to be driving seven hours a
day there you go but yeah I think you
know what to do Josh the hard part is
letting go of this amazing rent and
dealing with the idea of having a
roommate and moving again but man it it
is worth it you doubled your income and
there's got to be some sacrifices that
come along with that if you're going to
keep this job long term yep yeah I
appreciate it thank you yeah you got
this man you're not you're not doing
anything crazy I mean he's really
nervous about that rent I understand I
can't picture taking a road trip every
single day just to go to work and back I
when is he leaving the house 2:00 a.m.
he's probably not sleeping I didn't want
to ask that cuz I honestly it I was
afraid I was going to break out in a
rash just for him just the the the the
the anxiety of thinking about uh six to
did he say six to seven8 hourss Total 68
hours to we're talking that's probably
three or four each way I imagine and
then he goes well it was only a couple
days a week I don't care if it's once a
month that would drive me bananas no
thank you I don't like to be in a car
very long you need your beauty sleep you
don't get this with 3 hours 4 hours of
sleep look you know I got it it takes a
few minutes to do this hair too this
doesn't happen in a couple of minutes
there's a process here George we both
have our process well I don't think your
personal sanity your physical health
your mental health is worth commuting to
that job even if it's a dream job you're
living a nightmare do not forget that
that hampers your ability to do your job
well and potentially get promoted so
this is a holistic life decision here I
hope I hope he goes closer and I hope he
lives in pipsy cuz I like saying it Ken
was just dying for a call from pyy y'all
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 2 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi /
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey this is the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
this hour it's a free call at 882 5 5225
you call us up we'll talk about your
life your your work and your money and
hey if you're a new listener to this
show first of all welcome we know you
have a lot of options when you fly we
appreciate you checking this one out and
if you want to dive deeper into the
Ramsay baby steps and some of the lingo
we dish out on the show you can go to
ramseys solutions.com and click on the
get started button and we'll help you
figure out the next best step for your
journey based on where you're at today
that's Ramy solutions.com click on get
started by the way I should also say to
those who may want to come uh see us we
have a great group of people in the
lobby today when you said the whole uh
you have many choices when you fly if
you come watch the show live at our
world headquarters here just south of
Nashville uh we don't give you pretzels
and peanuts we give you fresh baked
goods Cookies Cakes uh lemonades bottle
water hot coffee cold coffee and uh yeah
so there you go and a free mug you get a
free mug yeah yeah I didn't know this
and of course it costs nothing to watch
the show although if times get tough I
guess we could charge and see if anyone
you know donations at the door kind of
thing that that is true we could but
it's a great time we love meeting people
from all around the world we had someone
from Germany met a nice lady from
Germany so who knew so we're open for
business come by and see us all right
Sean is in New Orleans I like how you
said that George noin noin how you doing
Sean I'm doing great you're talking to
one of the original George Hamill fans
here I was George Hamill fan before he
was a Ramy personality I I need to know
more what period of time was this this
was when he was uh doing the uh
commercial breaks you doing the doing
the I thought you were like from you
went to high school with me I appreciate
that I was hoping you were like his high
school shop teacher and you were about
ready to drop some knowledge on us so
okay good I love it well thank you Sean
no I'm all right let all get to the
question so I'm at the opposite end of
the uh uh Spectrum here you had to guess
there uh uh uh asking how to deal with
the four or fivey old kids and setting
them up I've got a 75y old mother who is
still working as flight attendant wow
saved up about saved up about a million
so we've been on uh a withdrawal plan
for the last 10 years since uh she was
65 so she only got about half of her
money in a Roth outside from the
withdrawals and the other half is in
regular cash and she has about a half
million left in the uh uh pre-tax 41k
portion so she's in the uh I guess the
winner of her life uh and is going to be
having a look at drawing down eventually
so my original plan was to uh do
tranches and annuitize the 500,000
as opposed to drawing down further but
with inflation uh I know that that's
been main concern that you'all been
talking about I I'm concerned that with
an annuity or or slowly annuitizing it
that if inflation does take off that it
will essentially destroy the value of
the uh of the monthly payments on the
annuity so one of the things I was
considering I know you know Dave is
typically not a fan of gold but uh as
far as the draw down portion to where
managing her finances over a 1 to n year
period in the liquid phase you know
beyond baby step three as far as the 3
to six months of emergencies uh funds uh
excuse me was to use a portion of that
not with physical gold the gold funds
you know that something that you can
easily uh uh turn into liquid cash you
know in the
market uh I just wanted to get you
thoughts on gold funds that that hold
physical gold on your behalf as a hedge
for somebody in the Twilight years to
try to protect their purchasing power
yeah of what they have uh so I just want
to give you thoughts on that well I
appreciate the question I love that
you're thinking about this to help your
mom you know retire with dignity and
keep this money alive as long as
possible but even a gold fund versus
gold itself the problem with gold is and
we talked about this on yesterday's show
with Dave is that it doesn't produce
anything and so what you're looking for
is a growth stock mutual fund companies
that have publicly traded stocks that
are focused on growth and what that does
they're producing something called
profit they're creating Revenue out
there in the economy and that's going to
give you a much higher return in the
long term and so what is that the
500,000 currently invested in inside of
that
401k so about uh 15 to 20% of it in in
the growth stocks that you talk about
the remaining uh and so it's a 401k it's
basically in the uh interest income fund
which I guess is drawn around
6% uh right now because my main concern
is you know just on a historical basis
growth stocks uh appear to be
significantly overvalued relative to
where the mean is O over history I think
the S&P for example typically trades at
a 15 multiple it's about 25 now so it
seems like the odds you're saying hey
what happened the last 30 40 years is
not going to happen the next 30 40 years
therefore I'm spooked I'm going to put
the money
elsewhere yeah the concern is I'm not
going to say that we're going to head
for an exact repeat of the 19 uh 30s uh
after the stock market crashed or
anything like that but it is a
possibility and if you know for somebody
who's 5 years of age or even 35 years of
age you know you're going to have you
know maybe 40 years to recover from that
but if my mother was to suffer a 50%
loss you know in her remaining 10 years
or 15 years of life I don't know that
we'd be able to recover for that does
she have a paid for house any
debt yeah she has no debt she rents and
so her rent we we calculated about
65,000 a year is what she would need to
live on 36% of that would represent the
rent around 2,000 a month including the
uh
you know garage and some other uh um
amenities that come with the rent and a
car which were AC crewing that 65,000
would acrew uh I don't know about two
two or three hundred a month to replace
the car and what's her monthly income
if uh her monthly well she used to make
an equivalent in today's terms 120,000
but she's down to 60,000 what do you
mean today's terms what what is her
paycheck
today paycheck today is 60,000 that's
because she's only working about she's
essentially working the equivalent
part-time I guess you would say got it
she she's not able to work the hours
that she used to do due to you know
getting older yeah that's a young man's
game that's I mean flight attendant is a
it's a lot on the body to travel that
much and that up and down in early
mornings and late nights but Sean I'll
tell you what I would tell you know my
mother who is not 75 yet but I would
still trust the US Stock Market
and I would still invest in those mutual
funds and index funds and if you want to
go a little more conservative you know a
7030 split and not have it all in stocks
that's okay but I would not turn out of
fear of what could be to things like
gold funds or us treasuries I don't
think it's going to beat inflation over
the long run and I truly have faith in
the US economy so that's just personally
what I would do uh I appreciate the call
though thank you so much Ken are you
with us here we got some feedback yeah
I'm actually here I'm not sure what's
going on something's happening in the in
my ears okay yeah we'll figure that out
yeah it's live we know we'll power
through it there we go whatever just
happened but Ken this is a this is a
real thing people getting spooked by the
US economy wanting to pull their money
out wanting to put it in things like
gold and other Commodities what do you
tell people when it comes to fear as it
relates to their life okay so we have to
figure out if fear is telling us the
truth and protecting us like if I were
to get on a Ledge okay overlooking a a a
very steep cliff and and fear says Whoa
back up now that's fear telling me
you're too close to the edge and it's
protecting me but many times fear is not
telling us the truth it's not
truth-based therefore it is holding us
back so we want to sit down and we want
to go okay let's just take this
situation okay because there's a lot of
I mean my goodness I I don't want to
take a shot at Facebook but I'm just
going to keep it real my dad is in his
70s the guy's on Facebook all day long
okay and it's just one scary link after
another link that this guy's clicking on
and the algorithm is feeding them and so
there are a lot of people going the
world is going to crash is coming to an
end and all this stuff that could happen
if it does the stock market and how much
money your mom has left over is the
least of your worries yeah so I would
act as though everything is going to be
fine and let's move forward that way and
that's how I would choose to take on
that fear that's a good plan and also
working with a financial adviser who can
show you real data real facts real
perspective and uh I would highly
encourage her to check out ramsy
solutions.com and get some help there
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the
[Music]
books hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsey Way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for the
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel co-host
of smart money happy hour we joined by
Ken Coleman host of the Ken Coleman show
and we are here to serve you today
America you can give us a call at triple
8825 5225 if you've got that burning
question don't be shy this is the day to
call Ken and I you know we're we haven't
been called intimidating many times in
our life you that's a great point in
fact we couldn't intimidate an ant let's
be honest I once fought n and I lost
exactly you know we we are we we have
fun together uh we enjoy being we're
here to help you we're not going to yell
at you we're going to encourage you and
George is one half of the wildly popular
Duo uh Rachel Cruz being the other half
of smart money happy hour and I'd like
to point out that in the yeti here is
just water thank you for pointing that
out no cocktails or mocktails on the set
today I am unever bet your advice would
be better though uh I I wonder that's
fair I wouldn't work any longer but uh
the advice would be great for one show
well if you want some of that advice you
can try out
8825 5225 John is kicking us off in
Seattle John welcome to the show
John hey guys thanks for taking my call
hey how you
doing good good um so my wife and I are
33 we've um we're on baby steps four
through six right now and um step four
we've got figured out the retirement
stuff and right now we're looking at
step five and six um we've got two kids
one more on the way and so I focusing in
on step five right now which is the kids
college fund um and the main question I
have is basically how much to put in
there for each of the kids because you
know it seems like
there's my view so basically my wife and
I both value education um I've got an
MBA and my wife's got a doctorate and
it's worked for us our careers made
sense we paid off our debt um and the
career path we chose made sense we have
constant discussion discussions about
you know we want our kids to go into
certain degrees certain areas maybe um
we're kind of discussing how much should
we put away should we cover their
undergrad should we set aside some stuff
for graduate like should we set them up
for our path I'm I'm personally on the
fence between you know I think 10 to 20
years from now uh you know the ROI on
certain degrees might not make sense
like if my son decides he wants to do a
six Monon uh plumber
course and become an apprentice and
start his own business and take some
business courses on the side and you
know start off with no debt I would
rather have that but at the same time
we're kind of talking about well if
they're going to go down the education
route we want them to have some skin in
the game because my wife and I both had
to pay student loans and it kind of
forced us to work while we were in
school good experience John let me jump
in for a second we're going to get to
the money piece how old are the
kids um so our oldest is five
youngest is two and then the other one's
on the way okay John first of all I love
your heart and I love that you're intent
on this but you need to breathe man uh
they're two and five like just enjoy
finger painting and sock puppets and
whatever else is going on okay that's
the first thing secondly um you asked
the question and maybe it was rhetorical
but I'm going to I'm going to take it
literally uh as a guy who is way further
down the the the path than you I'm only
speaking for experience you don't even
have to call this wisdom okay you have
no freaking idea what your kids are
going to decide to do you have no
freaking idea what the world of work is
going to look like at that point and
you're absolutely right about the ROI
the ROI on a college degree right now is
already plummeting and that world is
changing rapidly I talk about that
almost every day on the Ken Coleman show
as the work guy here at Ramsey I'm
focusing on the education piece that
qualifies you for work uh but but let me
also say you said should we steer them
should we push them in the direction
that we went
no no let your kids choose their own
path it's a it's a disaster situation
for parents to put pressure on these
kids to do what you did coming yeah
where I'm coming from with that is that
you know like if if there's all this if
there's a pot of money put aside and
they want to
do I don't know A Fine Arts degree or
something something to that nature um
that you know there would be
some stipulations attached to the money
maybe that you know the ROI would need
to be positive on it for them to do it
and we would want to have that disc but
those variables are not even fully in
your control so the the variable I would
put on it is we're going to give you
this money and you're going to graduate
from your undergrad in four
years yeah we're not going to slou
around we're not going to do this in six
years we're going to get good grades and
graduate or you're going to use that for
your plumbing trade school and you're
going to be a freaking awesome plumber
and you're just going to pull your pants
up higher than than most plumbers that's
all we ask just a little thing that's
big just for all of us can we all agree
on that one yeah so you know John like
put the money aside you can put it in a
529 and but don't underfund it to allow
them to go into debt to teach them A
Life Lesson listen I took on student
loan debt there was no wonderful lessons
I learned my life just would have been
better without student loans I worked
just as that was because I had great
parents who raised me well to work hard
now could we have done better on the
financial side and paid cash for college
that would have been great but as far as
work ethic and the character that your
kids are going to have you have a direct
influence on that we don't know if
they're going to go into Fine Arts or
they're going to be pro athletes or if
they're going to be YouTubers like Ken
and I we don't know and 20 years from
now we don't know what the world of work
looks like or the world of college looks
like so the best thing I can do is what
can I do today to set my kids up for
tomorrow and the next day and that means
throwing money into the 529 knowing we
don't know what the future holds and the
good news is John with the new secure
act 2.0 you can now convert up to 35
Grand of that money to a Roth IRA if
they don't use it for
college so not all
is would your recommendation be to do
the 529 then or should if I don't know
how much I'm ultimately gonna should I
just throw it in a brokerage account
it's the same thing no it's not the same
thing there's tax advantages with the
529 that you're not going to get with
the brokerage account and so I like the
the actual 529 the other thing is
brokerage account becomes well we want
to get a down payment on a rental
property cuz we H air bnb's hot and so I
like the 529 having a specific goal that
is meant for this child and again you
can always change beneficiaries what if
one of them goes to a really expensive
school and one of them does the trades
yeah and so there's a lot of options you
have when you have money the options
when you don't is student loan debt and
to me and my for me and my family that's
not an option it's off the
table Yeah Yeah but be prepared John I
want to prepare your heart because you
and your you and your wife uh represent
a lot of parents out there that I'm
speaking
to um you need to be okay if your kid
doesn't want to go get the fancy degree
at the fancy college that you went to
that does not mean they're losers and uh
college and and the value of a degree is
going to be so wildly different in in 15
16 18 years I can't even begin to tell
you all I'm telling you I'm telling you
right now folks it's going to be very
decentralized and splintered from the
offering that you see today um it's it's
there it's too much money it's too much
debt and it's so little relevance to the
American workplace right now right now
imagine what it's going to be like in 5
to S years you're going to have a bunch
of empty buildings and you know what I
say good riddens can I love I've heard
you say this before is a college degree
the only way and is it the best way to
the work you want to do let's focus on
the work we want to do instead of some
degree we want to get that's right we'll
have a generation that's actually happy
with their work and making good money
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours
and when you're intentional about making
good choices over time they become
Healthy Habits Like choosing to slow
down and make time for a daily practice
of prayer and meditation one thing that
has helped me with a daily practice of
meditation in prayer is hallow hallow is
the number one Prayer app in the world
and they're giving you three months free
to get started that's three months free
to prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com /
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camell joined by Ken Coleman this
hour give us a call at
5225 so Ken many moons ago oh just over
90 days ago great reference on the show
I said hey here's a challenge for the
listeners out there for the credit card
people cuz we talked about I did a poll
saying hey what is the reason you won't
cut up the credit card and there's a lot
of reasons right we got fraud
protections and love my rewards and it's
the convenience and fear security glands
flaring up and so I challenged everyone
to say hey for 90 days don't use your
credit card put it in a block of ice
lock it in a safe and just use your
debit card stick to cash and see how it
changes your spending so this has now
been 90 days and so what I want to do is
challenge the listeners if you actually
had committed to this I know you did cuz
about at least 67 people said I'm
committing to this 67 that's a great
that's a great response at least so I
got to go back through my DMs and find
it there's some homework on my end but
if that was you I need you to reach out
to me George camel with a K on Instagram
send me a DM if that was you now if you
didn't do the challenge don't bother me
all right but if this was you just uh
follow me at Ken Coleman so there how
about that yes you can talk to K Lon
yeah I love to get in the DMS there we
go no I don't but I'm I'm curious the
results of this I actually would like to
know thatal study can we say if if for
some reason you're listening right now
uh call in the show love that if you're
listening and you were one of those
people who said I committed here's what
happened let's let's put him put him to
the front of the line Christian and
let's see if we have someone who took
George up on his Challenge and they're
listening to us right now and they call
in and they they did not use their
credit card for 90 days my hypothesis
was you're going to spend way less
you're going to have way more margin and
you won't miss the precious rewards and
you're going to cut up that card once
and for all have you seen the
legislation that is pending in Congress
right now
have you heard about this well visa and
MasterCard have been fighting to
increase the transaction fees The
Interchange fees they charge to
businesses right and which will end up
by the way hurting the consumer because
what do businesses do you think they're
just going to take it and just pay the
extra 1% no they're going to increase
prices by they're going to pass it on
they're going to make your sweater a
little bit more expensive George exactly
and so we're all complaining about
inflation while getting excited about
our rewards cards which are causing all
of this to happen because guess what
visa and MasterCard are not gifting you
that out of generosity that's the fees
they need to make money in order to pass
on your rewards and which in turn makes
all of the things you buy more expensive
which in turn makes you complain about
inflation they love those rewards so
those could go away George yes I would
it would be a a great thing a great day
in America a great day in America if we
had to live without a rewards which by
the way 30 years ago 20 years ago was
not even a thing so the idea that you
can't live without a credit card I go
well how I just watched this Burger King
ad Ken did you see this it was a
1993 Burger King ad where they had just
started accepting credit cards and they
were interviewing people in the in the
restaurant going they were going oh my
gosh uh what do you think about this
they're going well I mean I can't
imagine someone swiping their credit
card for fast food right who's going to
do that yeah it's nuts do you remember
when the whole rewards thing actually
became a thing uh I mean it was in my
lifetime cuz I grew up up with it and so
at least I'm going to say 20 25 years
ago credit card company started becoming
I'm going to get you what color hat
would you like trucker hat solid color
it can't be red and and I'll explain
that in just a moment okay I'll go black
okay I'm going to get you a black
Trucker's hat that says Marfa on the
front of it m a RFA make America reward
free again wow I don't know if it'll
stick but I will proudly wear that hat
Ken it's probably not and now I
understand why it can't be red
thank you for that you see what I was
doing there yes because you were so
passionate like it would be a great day
in America if we had no more credit card
rewards so I thought well you need a
Marfa hat you heard great in America
make America reward free again I feel
like it's too many letters if you've
ever wondered what it's like to be
inside the brain of Ken Coleman that was
a great picture there it is it's like a
15-year-old and a 75-year-old all at
once yeah it's an old man with a young
brain I love it thank you for that Ken
thank you I feel like that's a
compliment I'll I'll report back as I uh
start to inquire with all the people
that committed to the challenge but I
can't wait to see the result challenge
all right let's get to the phones Gina
is in Sacramento Gina welcome to the
show thank you for taking my call I have
a quick question on investing um I'm on
baby steps four and six and I've always
heard that you should contribute to your
company retirement plan to get the match
but what about when the rate of return
is really low and I'm having better
returns in my Roth Ira should I just max
that out instead I don't see it as an
either or and so if you look at our
investing strategy it's five words math
beats rth beats traditional and so what
is your match with your
employer so if I contribute 4% they will
contribute 2% and that's the maximum
okay great so we're going to take that
first because that's a 100% return so
regardless of what the fund is that
you're invested in you just doubled your
money instantly right
but so at least I pay attention should I
pay attention to what the annualized
rate is of return or the cumulative the
annualize is what you're looking for and
you want to look at this over a long
period of time so I wouldn't be looking
one year in four years and for the F
past four years my annualized rate of
return is
1.55% okay and what about your Roth
IRA uh that is 4.8 okay so what you want
to look at is what am I invested in in
the Roth IRA what actually makes up is
it a a mutual fund inside of there what
are you invested
in uh yeah it's just I picked the fund
and then it just does its thing okay so
what I would do is look in with your
four your 403b plan and say what am I
invested in is it am I did I choose some
rough funds do I need to change my
allocations going forward and that's
what I would do and usually there's
going to be a financial advisor tied to
your hr's 403b plan that you can reach
out to with those kinds of
questions and if there isn't you can
always reach out to a smartvestor pro
okay that sounds good thank you yeah you
got it that's a great question and I
don't want you to get hung up because a
lot of people Ken we always spout these
these numbers we say Hey you can get 11%
annual average return if you invest in
the stock market and they go where's my
11% I'm getting 4% this year and I'm
going well yeah I never said every
single year on command it's going to be
an exact 11% I mean I'm looking here Ken
at the this chart right this is the S&P
500 this represents the 500 largest uh
most established companies and that's
really what we call the stock market
they they represent the overall stock
market and in 2020 we had a return of
18.4% everyone would say that's amazing
2021 28% in 2021 and then 2022 happened
and everyone freaked out because it was
negative 18% what are we on track for
right now what and we are back up so far
17% and so when you look at those
numbers and K you can see this chart
there's a whole lot of blue which means
we're up and a whole little bit of red
and so when you look at the long-term
track record of the stock market most of
the time it's trending up and yes if you
look at a given period 6 months period a
month a year period you may not see 11%
or 18% or
20% but overall what you're looking for
is a good solid mutual fund it has a
good track record record it's invested
in the right kinds of companies we
recommend splitting it into four
different types of mutual funds so
you've got growth growth in income
aggressive growth and international and
what that does it just diversifies it
just says hey let's not put all of our
eggs in the silic and Valley basket of
all these hot Tech startups let's not
put all of our eggs in the old big
companies like the Home Depot of the
world and let's also invest in some
International companies like Samsung or
Nestle so that if the US market takes a
dip we found there tends to be a inverse
relationship where the international
funds could balance that out and so
that's all you're doing and over the
course of your investing Journey which
is not a year it's 20 years 30 years 40
years you're going to see great returns
and you will thank us later so you can
look into it I wouldn't stress I don't
look at my 401k every 3 months to see am
I up am I down I just invest for the
Long Haul and once a year once every six
months I'll check it just to see what's
going on but I don't stress out about it
yeah I I I don't even think about it I
just know that what the average is
saying it's going to be great and just
hold on to it and uh you know there's so
much fear-mongering out there and so
much news about everything that's bad
you'd be surprised if he just took three
days just three and didn't pay attention
to the news at all how much better you
feel and then check back in and go huh
my life doesn't suck that's right and
remember this it's not about timing the
market it's about time in the market
don't jump off the roller coaster until
the ride is over my friends this is the
[Music]
show hey guys being free to make your
own medical decisions is a big deal
these days Christian Healthcare
Ministries gives members the freedom to
choose the doctors and providers they
want without the frustration of worrying
about networks and with no waiting
period to join it's a membership based
nonprofit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so see if chm could be right for
your family check out more today at
chministries.org
budget
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George camel
joined by Ken Coleman this hour
88255 5225 we are here for you helping
you take the right next step in your
life in your work and your money Martha
is up next in Orlando Martha welcome to
the
show hi thank you for taking my call
first of all sure um I've got a quick
situation I'm getting ready to retire in
the next couple years I'm debt free and
um my question is I don't get a lot I
won't have a lot of income coming in uh
once I retire I am self-employed like I
said not going to get much in in Social
Security so therefore I've got a couple
investment properties who actually
generates income right now so I was
thinking um my personal home the
Homestead Property if it's twice to do a
a reverse mortgage on that take that
money from that and buy another property
cash obviously and use that as income
rent it out and use the money as income
where did you hear about this idea of
the reverse
mortgage oh I'm in I'm in real estate oh
okay so you know the ins and outs of
these deals yes oh boy and it still
sounds like a good idea to you yes
because um you know even though Tom
celic is selling these schlepping them
on late night
television yes oh boy well I have strong
feelings against reverse mortgages so I
cannot in good faith tell you or anyone
else who would call into the show that
this is a wise decision for their
financial future it puts your home at
risk it's adding more debt to your name
it's causing you to go backwards
financially and the interest in fees can
reduce that Equity even further and if
you don't meet the loan obligations you
know what happens you're in real estate
foreclosure yes yeah but um the real the
home um the reverse mortgage is until
you pass away you can stay there as long
as you
can sure but I'm confused why this is a
money-making scheme to do the reverse
reverse mortgage to get a
rental because I'll get the equity I got
from my home take half of it okay and
put it into another home is home paid
for for it huh is the home paid for yes
so you have no payments on the home and
we're going to create a payment they're
going to pay you by robbing your Equity
over time no they're not going to pay me
I'm going to take all the equities on
that house and put it into so you're
talking about a home equity
loan no no no no you can take the the
funds a lump sum a lump sum okay and
that's what you would do enough that's G
to give me more than 400 C 500,000 which
I can use and purchase an uh another
home and then generate income that way
that's essential like you saying hey
should I go take out a mortgage for
$500,000 as a retirement
plan yeah but I'm not pain on it how are
you I don't understand how you don't
think this debt is attached to your
name it is attached but I'm not making
payments I need to make income well this
isn't the plan if we're talking about
making income this is a dis better plan
so you have rentals what are the rental
properties
worth um one is worth 400,000 okay and
the other
one is 880,000 okay and are they paid
for do you have mortgages on them no
they're paid for everything's paid for
and what's your current house
worth it's over 900,000 love it and do
you have anything else to your name any
other assets anything in
retirement very little okay so on paper
I'm seeing you have $1.5 million in real
estate or so M so wouldn't this be a
better plan if you're looking at making
income why don't we sell maybe your
personal maybe we sell everything and we
figure out new living situation so that
you can free up that cash and invest
that
instead cuz these rental properties what
are they making and investing I don't
know how to invest I've got burn in in
in all these Investments and well I want
you make wise Investments there's a
broad spectrum from sucks to amazing
when it comes to investing but I'm
telling you you don't have to do this
rental income plan what what are they
bringing in total what's the net profit
per
month I will say they bring like
2400 okay and that's not enough for you
to live off of on top of Social Security
no okay so how much do you need to live
off of I need at least another I will
say about seven Grand you have $10,000
in expenses with no payments I like I
like to
travel you don't have enough money to
that's not a living expense that's like
me saying George asking me Ken how much
you need to live off of and I throw a
huge number out there and I go well I
like to drive I need I told you no
that's not what you need no that's not
no George has been very nice I'm going
to be very honest with you you need
$7,600 every single month to travel no
well first of all no stop you don't need
to
travel need is to pay I know but I'm I'm
irritated listening to all this Martha
we irritated everything is paid okay I
got my card he's getting a little aut
you don't need $10,000 you don't need 10
grand
you need to pay for your utilities you
need to pay for your food you need to
pay for your clothes Transportation uh
other other miscellaneous expenses you
can save up but you don't need that kind
of money and to take out a loan from
your Equity a reverse mortgage to get
another house to spit off a little bit
of money for all of the risk and all of
the upkeep and everything else it's just
nonsensical it doesn't make any sense I
would rather you sell all your
properties and scale back your living
and you're going to going have a very
nice Nest
EG yeah I guess so I guess you're right
yeah I mean you know I mean you decide
less travel for me then that means less
travel less spending money Le but less
risk debt is risk how old are you Martha
I'm 61 okay my God how many more working
years do you have now it's going to give
another couple more years okay what's
your
income huh what's your income aside from
the rental properties what do you do for
a living and how much do you make we uh
we generate a good 200 right now who's
we my husband and I okay so he's working
as well does he have any assets or is
this what you laid out is that
everything between the both of you do
everything for us okay so what if we put
this 200 to good work for the next 5
Years cuz you know what 200,000 is for
five years that means a million dollars
is going to pass through your fingers
over the next 5
years MH now what most people do is they
wake up and go oh my gosh we made Grand
we're doing our taxes I don't know where
it all went we got nothing to show for
it or you could take advantage of all
these catchup contributions start maxing
out your retirement accounts start
socking away money and have some
retirement with dignity that's my goal
for you but the way to do it you've done
such a great job getting these places
paid off and now you're telling me you
want to go back into
debt which is not going to set you up in
retirement I don't see as a debt because
I you don't see a mortgage as a
debt no because that's something to
they've done some really great marketing
then haven't they it's literally in the
program it's called a reverse mortgage
do you know where the word mortgage
comes from it's a French word death
pledge okay did you know
that it's a real fun dark fact for you
Martha and so if you're telling me
that's not debt when the word death
pledge is in it I don't know what to
tell you you call the wrong show today
but I want you to have an amazing
retirement I want you to travel and I
also know that going into debt is going
to hinder your ability to travel and
right now we're getting star eyed over
what a rental income could do for us and
I also know during coid you couldn't
even collect rent it was a moratorium
and it caused a lot of people to freak
out for good reason true that part is
true and so that I don't want you in a
situation like that and what happens if
the HVAC goes or the renters don't pay
or you have trouble filling that spot
it's not a fullprof Mone over in the
Amalfi Coast you know what are you going
to do then I would set some goals over
what we're going to do for the next five
years because I don't want you working
in your
70s okay is that fair that's fair okay
and I would not be scared of the stock
market if you are keep listening to the
show connect with one of our smart
Vestor Pros they've got a a heart of a
teacher and this is a network of
investing professionals across the
country they don't work for us but they
will take care of you and help guide you
along this investing journey and give
you some peace that your money's not
going to disappear here are you you were
serious about the mortgage it's a French
word for death real I thought you might
have been mess with her no you can
Google this folks I wonder how you say
it Pledge morgage our team just put it
up there French Mort death wow Gage
pledge George you blew my mind I'm full
of fun facts if you guys ever want to do
a trivia night around mortgages take me
with you I'll be your Huckleberry this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100% satis
faction guarantee and shipping is always
free Cy blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
hey folks welcome back to the Ramsey
Show I'm George camel joined by Ken
Coleman it's a free call at 8825
5225 my mama always told me that sharing
is caring Ken and so I'd really
appreciate it a if everyone out there if
you enjoy the show consider sharing it
with a friend hitting the share button
wherever you're listening leave a review
and uh just tell people about it hit the
Subscribe button let the algorithms know
you're into it so that we can displace
all the filth that's out there all the
toxic advice that's uh constantly
swirling around us and I know it is
because you guys send it to us going
have you guys seen this you got to talk
about this on the show and so one of the
ways we can help with that is getting to
the top of your YouTube algorithms and
podcast algorithms so that people know
we're out here telling them the truth
even when it hurts so we really
appreciate that and you know throw a
little something extra in if you like
George and I together we've been called
the root beer float of the r show so uh
we we very proud of that moniker I don't
know why but it's something I it's it's
on my wall yeah is it really picture of
me and you 8 by10 root beer float across
the top I say that now some some fan is
going to send us an 8 by 10 I know we
don't no we we're joking we're just
having fun it's going to be the Step
Brothers movie poster but with our faces
on it instead yeah root beer float you
know why we do this show George why for
people like chappie online too that's
right I've been waiting this might be
the first chappie in years the first
chappie I've ever talked to in my life
and I couldn't be morec Cha's gonna
deliver out in San Francisco what's up
chappie how's it going chappie I'm
curious is that a god-given
name uh if God is my mother then
possibly but uh no my real name
unfortunately is Christopher but I've
gone by CH i' stick with chappie three
months old that's awesome nobody knows
me as Christopher I don't even answer to
Christoper well and we will not call you
that you are chappie to us and that's
all you'll ever be I love it how can we
help
today uh well I want to say thank you
for all the great content conversations
really enjoyed the stuff with uh Alex
her Moi and gr Stefan and whatnot oh
thank you my question is around student
loans um as many are at my age around 30
years old um so I've got some cash on
hand but I have currently student loans
of about $117,300 and basically the
question is should I just take all the
cash and you know one lump sum payment
you know basically the end of this month
pay it all off um or kind of you know
break that down to whatever $1,000 do a
month you know smaller you know multiple
payments how much cash do you
have um in total like cash on hand
across across cash savings and
Investments
113,000 I've got 30 odd in uh a savings
account that was for a house um but
didn't buy a house you know so Market
was challenging to get into and then
obviously interest rates go up so
basically taking you know that
17K that's owed out of the 30,000 that I
have um and just paying it all off dude
pay it off today yes like right now on
the phone with us would be even better
just bam done sign in log on click yeah
done what's holding you back why are you
wanting to do it over a longer period of
time um I it's just like the shock value
of like taking $177,000 out of my
account you know writing that check you
know what's even greater shock value
taking out $177,000 in student loan
debt yeah yeah we don't even we don't
even blink L and I when we let students
do this do we here's 80 grand we don't
know we've never even seen 80 grand good
for you way to go future is going to be
great you're 100 Grand in debt woohoo
that's a great impression Ken it they
sound just like that it I think it does
yeah so chappie I'm paying this thing
off today man I'm never looking back I
don't think you're going to regret it I
understand that's a lot of money to see
blown in one Fell Swoop but that's
exactly what you need to do is get out
of debt as soon as possible because that
means those next paychecks all stay with
you that's is you're not worried about
what the next headline is around student
loans you're just going huh big change
the channel just a fun exercise real
quick chappie like uh let's just assume
that you've that you've paid it off
right now how do you think that's going
to feel what what what do you think
that's going to be uh what's it going to
feel like
emotionally feel good uh also seeing my
bank account drop I didn't ask you that
I didn't ask you that annoying but no no
it would be nice to be to be Dey and
then be able to take you know
what is $300 a
month well the truth is chappie that 17
grand it doesn't have your name on it in
your bank account it looks like it does
it's got Sally May's name on it yeah but
let's focus how much money will you have
left after paying the 17
off um whatever 113 minus 173 hey bro
that's a lot of money for a debt-free
guy who's got a huge future in front of
them I'm I'm trying to change your
mindset you're so hung up on watching 17
disappear from your bank account but you
forgot that you're watching 17 disappear
from your
debt balance sheet still 95k remaining
95k debt free and $300 a month raise
that's what you should be thinking about
I'm going to tell you what's going to
happen after you do
that chappie is going to be
happy I had to do it how did I not get
there first I'm a little upset with
myself yeah I'm so proud of you man we
want to see a happy chappie be gone this
is Ken's new tagline for the rest of the
hour we should move on to the next call
cuz I can't stop myself it's like a
toddler just it just sounds too good I
love it well next up is a less exciting
name but a beautiful name Brooke is with
us in Oklahoma City how are you
Brooke Brooke I'm good how are you guys
good how are
you well kind of have a situation and I
was hoping to get some advice or just
any ideas on how you know I could mess
up my financial situation or fix my
messed up financial situation okay
what's wrong with it okay okay so I was
living with my grandparents and it
became a very toxic environment because
my grandma has uh bipolar you know that
you how what that can be like um and I
was living
there uh you know no bills I was going
to school and I ended up running a
balance with the school I was going to
so I basically had to drop out because I
had no way to pay for it and get a job
while I was working a job it wasn't
making enough at all I then I got an
apartment and I found a different job
where I made a little bit
more
but it just it wasn't it wasn't cutting
it and I every month I was living
paycheck to paycheck and so I thought
okay well let's get another job try to
find something more high paying and no
one is going hire me without a degree
that's just a simple fact not true not
true not true okay well okay so I see
what you mean but I thought do you have
a job right now back to school I do okay
what do you what do you make 52k Year
good for you without a degree without a
degree I thought you just said no one's
going to hire you without a degree
you're making
52k well yes but I it's not enough to
pay my bills what are your bills do you
have debt I yes I've I've in order to
live here I've I've maxed out my credit
cards I've taken out different loans and
I'm working full-time and going
full-time at school because I found a a
grant to get my f or my school account
right okay Brooke let's pause let's just
say we put this this whole thing on
pause and we go let's get a financial
Foundation under us let's get ahead of
these payments let's clean up this debt
let's stop maxing out the cards could
you do that cuz right now you're running
a million miles an hour just speaking I
imagine that's how your life is too and
we want to help you with
that one of the things I'm going to
recommend is and George I want you to
give her some stuff to help it really
fast you have got to pause on school you
do not need to be going to school
full-time full stop pause I don't care
about the grant stop and you need to be
working a second maybe a third job to
get your income up in the short term so
that we can get control of your debt and
your expenses like let's stabilize your
financial life then we'll worry about
the professional choices absolutely and
broe I'm going to do you one better I'm
going to gift you one year of our
premium version of every dollar and
here's what I want you to do go to
everydollar.com budgeting all everyone
listening can do this I'm doing a free
training on September 26th on how to
break the paycheck to paycheck cycle in
90 days this was made specifically for
people like you it's at 12:30 Eastern
Time 11:30 central time and I'm going to
walk you through how to use our tool to
become debt free to get that emergency
fund filled up to create that margin and
you're going to be so excited to budget
so hang on the line I'm going to gift
you one year of that and then join us
everydollar.com budgeting for that
webinar and uh I'm going to walk you
through that specifically and say hey
I'm Brooke from the show I'll get put
you right to the front of the line to
get your question answered Brooke thank
you so much for the call that puts this
hour of the ramsy show in the
books hey it's Ken if you love the show
and want to deeper dive live on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way go to ramsy solutions.com
today to sign up for our newsletter
again that's Ramy solutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my colleague Ken
Coleman and we are here for you this
hour taking your calls at
5225 now of course I would love to take
your money questions and Ken always
dutifully jumps in with some great
advice but Ken's expertise lies in the
work space purpose and work there's so
many people out there struggling with
that K and it's inex inextricably tied
to money because Dave always says your
greatest wealth building tool is your
income yeah 98% of net worth
millionaires said that they loved their
work so the idea of getting up on Monday
and you're going to have some bad days
some long days but the idea that you can
do work that you really are good at that
you enjoy that creates results that you
care about uh that is not pipe dream
that's not a Fantastical you know
nursery rhyme so we're here to help with
that to get you in the right seat of the
bus on the right bus and watch your
money watch your relationships watch
your health every area of your life
improve love it well let's get it kicked
off with TJ in Chicago TJ welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey good afternoon Ken and George
thank you so much for taking my call
bet well I got kind of a a work life
balance question for you and I'm
wondering to try to get your input on it
sure um basically I'm 43 um I've worked
multiple jobs my whole life up to three
jobs my parents owned a a local
restaurant I cooked that for 10 plus
years and uh went to college and trade
school um worked in the automotive
industry and uh when I graduated from
high school I actually started and I
currently own and operate my own
mobile DJ service so I worked three jobs
gone seven days a week um me and my wife
when we we got married we were high
school sweethearts we got married uh we
made the joint decision that uh she
would be home and to raise our three
boys which she had done and did a great
job with well now uh like I said we're
both 43 now she wants me home a little
bit more and I'm finding myself Str
struggling you know to try to find um
mentally and adjust myself to to not
work as hard or or work as much as what
I was doing um like I said we both own
our own businesses she works part-time
she pretty much picks her own hours um
I'm gone pretty much all the weekends 43
weekends a year um I work week job with
the mobile DJ stuff so the mobile
why can't you hire some some young blood
to go out there and travel for you well
that's the problem I do I do have I do
have another crew that goes with
me to me it's not work it's a passion I
love it I wish okay so hold on a second
days a week so so are you still working
three jobs or just the one mobile DJ on
the weekends and the 40 hour job during
the week yep I'm yep I'm a sales rep for
a company okay in the Chicago area yep
so what kind of money are you making as
a mobile DJ how close to matching or uh
uh over overcoming your current day job
over I make more than what I do at my
full-time job I make roughly 105,000 a
year DJing I make about 93 with my sales
job so you this begs the question why
aren't you knocking the uh the uh 40
hour a week job off and more time with
Mama and doing what you love on the
weekends well health insurance that's
the biggest one health insurance and I I
I I it's it's bad and my wife she says
it too I'm I'm greedy you know why not
make the money while I can you're going
to lose your wife you want to lose your
wife gonna lose your wife over this no I
right and that's what she says to me
she's like you know not too many wives
would uh want their husbands gone as as
much as you are
but I have not missed out on any of our
family functions we do have one St
oldest is going to college
TJ your wife wants you to to slow
down yes she may have been agreeable but
I don't think she's going to continue to
be agreeable and this isn't good for you
and I'm going to suggest to you that
there's more to it than greed I don't I
think that's a I think that's a cheap
excuse for you as to why you're working
all the time I'm not trying to put you
on the spot I don't want to in any way
um uh attack you and I there's something
going on with you where you need to be
busy all the time and you've got your
wife crying out gently saying I want you
here I want us to have more time
together you've done a great job so far
you got your kids out they're doing
their thing you're financially great
you've got this passion project which is
spending off more money than your day
job and I think there's something that
you're running from and I think the
busier you are the less you have to
listen to it
am I right or am I wrong and I don't
mind being
wrong no you're yeah you're absolutely
right I feel like I got to be doing
something all the time I just can't like
sit down and yeah but there's a reason
there's a reason for that and you're
you're and you need to you need to sit
with a counselor and a therapist and
let's and I'm not going to put you on
the spot here but I'm telling you you're
like the people who run all the time
ultra marathoners they're running from
something they just are I'm not
attacking I'm not no no listen some
people are smiling in the booth listen
I'm telling you if you're all the time
like every spare minute of your day
you're exercising or running it's
because you're trying to stay ahead of
something as opposed to meeting it head
on and you've admitted this and your
wife is crying out for you and you
better listen and I'm just going to tell
you you need to figure out why you want
to be working all the time cuz that's
not natural which means it's not
healthy right nope you're absolutely
right 100% right so TJ there's a few
options here number one you drop the DJ
stuff you choose the local gig sping
drop the DJ he loves that he loves it
but what if he could do the local ones
and hire the team out and he still makes
some money off of that he can still
choose yeah or you leave this full-time
job you just DJ and that's what you do
when you're home all week with your wife
and you're gone on the weekends he get
healthy but we can't continue doing all
of this multiple jobs never at home and
your wife wondering did I sign up to be
single cu the kids are gone now she's
really feel what she said dude that's a
word for word of what exactly she said
now we only have one of our of our sons
is is in college and we're cashal that
so he's going to college debt-free and
we have two other Sons one's a junior in
high school and the other is in eighth
grade so we do have even more but it's
even more important that you're in the
home I misunderstood I thought all three
were gone now it's even double important
that you're there and don't get and
don't play the I'm at all their sporting
events doesn't matter if you're not
around the house and you're not there
you're setting a precedent and an
example for your boys that it's okay to
be checked out as long as you say you're
working or you're busy and that couldn't
be further from the truth and I listen I
know that sounds tough it's not my
heart's hurting for you and your wife
I'm glad you admitted it I want you to
go see a counsil I'm going to challenge
you you need to be in a couple therapy
sessions before 30 days is up and begin
to dive in deep as to what's got you you
running so fast what are you running
from healing Health everything's on the
other side of that thanks for the call
TJ this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman this
hour open phones at
5225 so Ken as you know I'm now
officially a YouTuber like you you were
always my mentor my role model and so we
that's just couldn't be further from the
truth you're you're you're you're
crushing it you're out doing all the
cool videos well we we have Finance we
have a personal finance YouTube channel
a lot of people looking for advice
financially from YouTube and so we're
trying to step into that space we've had
the Channel since April thank you to all
of you who have subscribed we're already
approaching 100,000 subscribers there
but Ken this video that uh went up today
is currently the highest performing
video we've ever done and it correlates
to what you talk about and here's the
title what it takes to be financially
secure in America so it's about this
magic salary and there was a report that
said people need
$233,000 to feel financially secure okay
which I know I'm waiting you were
scoffing moments ago at that yeah it's a
little high and so we addressed that in
the video but I wanted your take because
a lot of people think well I need to
make this astronomical salary in my work
otherwise I'm screwed I'm never going to
make it I'll never hit my goals woe is
me I need to ask my boss for a raise
yeah the corporate toxic culture is the
thing holding me down what what is the
truth about salary well first of all uh
let's just go to some real data instead
of boo feelings over facts Ken I know I
know know so first we know that uh that
teachers are the third largest group of
net worth millionaires the average or
not the average the median rather the
median salary for teachers in this
country is about $61 $63,000 one of
those two if memory serves and so that
is a function of those teachers are
living on less than they make and as a
result they are very secure uh were
their seasons were their years where
maybe it was tight for them yes but what
did they do they adjusted their income
they adjusted their expectations that's
what I want to drop in here so here's
what happens the reason I'm shaking my
head when I hear that
$233,000 is this from a study uh some
type of study or poll okay y this is a
legitimate study here's what concerns me
about that bank rate 2023 is 2023 study
we that means there are a lot of
Americans a lot who have unrealistic
expectations now let me tell you what
happens with unrealistic
expectations un realistic
expectations of making
$233,000 a year because let me just tell
you very few people make that kind of
money if you look at the I wish I had
that number but it would shock you how
few people in America make less than
$150,000 all right unrealistic
expectations lead to unmet expectations
o so you think about a kid you when
we're parenting kids you know we're
always trying to help their expectations
be realistic why because we want them to
not be devastated and so so young people
and immature
people uh have these crazy expectations
and so you put out this number and it's
so hard to get to and it's so
unrealistic based on the way they're
living and acting now I can teach
anybody how to make
$233,000 but it but some people are
going to get to it faster than
others
okay uh and so and and so their
expectations are so unrealistic and
their lifestyle doesn't have anything in
it that would allow them to get there so
here's what happens then they start they
hope and they wish and they hope and
they wish and they hope and they wish
and all of a sudden it turns into
Despair and frustration and anger and I
deserve this and I deserve that that's
where this is going for so many people
and so it's so wildly outsized and it's
crazy talk because they're looking at
their life with how much debt they have
the kind of house they want so in that
number of 233 I'm guessing is a bigger
house than they've ever had before based
on their mom and daddy had or whatever
and so and no sacrificing of their
current sacrifice that's another big one
yeah like I drove a piece of garbage the
first four years of my marriage I mean I
I've joked about a Ford tourist I was
driving to work one day didn't have air
conditioning and I was driving to work
and it was hot and humid and I was at a
stoplight and all of a sudden I felt
something on top of my head I thought
was that a fly or something and I went
up and it was the freaking ceiling
carpet whatever you call it l fell down
on my head and I got home at night and I
went and got a stapler power stapler you
know oh yeah staple gun out of the
garage staple gun thank you just went I
was picturing office space like red
stapler just up there to your point
staple gun put three Staples in the top
and drove that way for another year but
it's all about sacrifice like I didn't
need a car and you learn how to live on
what you make currently that's the point
and suddenly you make more cuz you're
not desperate with the Long View in mind
so have too many people thinking about a
number that's really hard to get to
instead of looking at their actual life
and what they want their life to look
like and where were they sacrifice of
what matters most that's the problem and
in America we we've been conditioned by
all the social media all the television
commercials that the American dream is
equal to the American stuff and all the
nice Sizzle stuff so this is a real
problem George for this generation
because you're going to have a lot of
really unhappy people because they have
unrealistic expectations I I hate to go
so deep on it you're you're dead on but
that's what's underneath that number
yeah and so we always tell people it's
about your income yes you can get your
income up but it's also learning to live
on less than you make and what that
sometimes means is we have to cut our
lifestyle down to nothing for a season
to get out of debt which frees up
payments and all of a sudden you go oh I
can live off
$6,000 I just can't also have a car loan
a mortgage a student loan and max out my
credit cards
so we have to make some compromises here
and I walk people through it in this
video you can go check it out on my
YouTube channel we'll Link in the show
notes if you want to check that out or
you can just search for George camel
with a K on YouTube and pipe in with
your thoughts in the comments as people
tend to do Ken you get in there still uh
I peruse you know sometimes I'll give a
little like or a dislike what are what
are you what's your big takeaway in the
video what are you saying in your video
uh well the big takeaway is that I
believe everyone can learn to live on
what they currently make now there's the
exceptions to the rule if you're in
poverty and you or you make $25,000 a
year and you're trying to live in a
certain area it's going to be tough but
for most people Ken they make good money
it just disappears because they're
giving it all to a financial system
designed to take it from them and so I
believe that I could help you budget
your way out of most fiascos are you
getting killed on this or are people
agreeing with you that's a great
question can I haven't searched today
I've been busy at work but the top
comments are a lot of people uh saying
hey that was me I was that guy living
paycheck to paycheck wondering when it
was going to change for me wondering
when someone else was going to fix all
my problems and the truth is Ken I have
a lot of empathy because it's a tough
time out there with inflation and the
housing market and cost of living has
gone up and the groceries a little
higher but I don't think it's impossible
I'm still very optimistic that this is
still the best time in American history
to build wealth yeah our parents didn't
have side hustles they could go do like
we do today we can't jump on an app and
just download it and go make some money
and so the opportunity that's out there
and we meet these people they're 18
years old and they're running businesses
making six figures with no college
degrees Y and so don't tell me it's not
possible just tell me you're not willing
to do what it takes to get there that's
fine we can agree on that not everyone
wants to work that hard y but I I
believe there's so much opportunity out
there and we've seen too many people on
a debt free stage going I'm a teacher
who made 35,000 a year I'm 71 years old
and I became debt free we had a couple
yesterday 58 and 62 7 years later their
completely debt-free house and
everything they never made more than
$100,000 a year in their lifetime wow
and they're millionaires with a paid for
house Y and so I'm just here to tell you
it can be done once we put the excuses
away once we say all right despite
inflation despite who's President
despite the grocery cost we're going to
build wealth anyways and there is
something so rock and roll about going
I'm in control I'm not letting anyone
steal my joy my thunder my paycheck my
peace you're Invincible at that point
and that's what we see on the Deb free
stage is people who are invincible to
life you know there's something
underneath all of this that we've been
talking about is that certain people
just are able to pay
attention yes to what's going on in the
world but just kind of go you know what
I'm going to March to the Beat of My Own
Drum and I'm not going to get hung up on
all that other stuff I'm not going to
say I got to have this car I'm not going
to say I've got to travel on these trips
I'm not I'm just going to do my life the
way that I believe I'm supposed to do it
not get hung up in all the comparison
stuff and in Embrace contentment that's
huge um and that's so sad underneath
that data is so sad I know well I'm
going to be walking people through the
September 26th I'll do a free virtual
training 12:30 Eastern 11:30 Central
Time how to break this paycheck to
paycheck cycle how to make your income
that you currently have enough all by
doing a budget by paying attention to
your money and by simple little
sacrifices you can join it go to Every
dollar.com budgeting it's completely
free we'll see you then this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
w
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman hey
our buddy Dr John delone has got a brand
new book coming out called building a
non-anxious life you may have heard
about it a time or two on the show but
let me tell you time is running out to
get all the bonuses and and youall know
I like to take advantage of a good deal
and this is as good as it gets 75 bucks
in free bonus items and if you're
wondering what is the pitch for this
book well we all know that anxiety is a
pandemic Across the Nation it's
everywhere but anxiety isn't the problem
John delone says the problem is that
we're unsafe we're disconnected we're
unhealthy and we're living like we have
no say in what happens next life just
happens to us and so Dr deloney walks
you through the six daily choices to
recognize and break free from a life
spending out of control and you're going
to learn effective techniques to
identify and respond to all of life's
challenges and transform your life so
pre-order today it's 20 bucks and you
get 75 in free bonus items by doing that
including access to his newest talk
smoke fire and freedom as well as the
ebook and audiob book of building a
non-anxious life all for 20 bucks go
pre-order today at ramsy solutions.com
Shireen joins us up next in DC Shireen
welcome to the
show Hi how are you doing great how are
you doing well thank you thanks for
taking my call today sure um so yes I'm
calling in I'm actually new to this
whole program I um just started about
two weeks ago so I've been uh doing yeah
I've been doing the classes online uh
watching a couple of the YouTube videos
um I did download the every dollar app
so I've been working on that and I'm
trying to uh get clarity of everything
that's going on which is not pretty def
is to look at the first time around it's
very hard yes but it's definitely eye
opening um and I'm just not sure I guess
kind of where to start um I do have debt
I am the single parent of two uh School
AG children uh two two School AG kids
and um I do work one job um so I'm not
really sure where to start okay so how
much debt do you
have um so I have about 29 ,000 in
school loans um about 9,000 in credit
cards and another like
6500 in like medical bills um and lawyer
fees okay and no car payment no car
payment okay and you're
renting uh so I live with family but I
do pay rent here and I do own a home as
well oh what's going on with this home
um so I lived in it for about two years
and I ended up moving uh back with
family just because I need help with my
kids um so I'm actually using it as a
rental property now okay what does that
bring in what's the net
profit um
so it's about I know the rental there is
about 2,100 and the mortgage is like
1,200 okay now what is your income from
this one
job um I make about
4800 a year 48,000 a year oh sorry sorry
48,000 yes correct okay and that's your
gross pay versus take-home correct okay
so you're taking home less than that mhm
okay well that helps us thank you for
going through all the numbers so your
question was how do I even get started
this debt is crippling um based on your
numbers you shared here looks like you
got about $45,000 in debt total yes okay
well the the best way to eat an elephant
is one by at a time so that's what I'm
going to encourage you to do do you have
any money in the bank
currently uh no so let's say $ Z to your
name getting by paycheck to paycheck all
right what's the rental property
worth um it's worth about
one or excuse me it's about 278 right
now 278 what do you owe on
it uh I owe
166 okay so you've got about a 100 Grand
of equity in that home yes okay well
there is one option that's kind of the
nuclear option if you wanted to do it
and that is sell the rental because
we're not in a place to be homeowners
let alone Real Estate Investors right
now because you're feeling the crunch
you're living with family I want you to
get out of this and I want you to be
real estate investor if that's what your
heart wants but right now it's not even
fun right like you're making a little
money off of this but one thing goes
wrong what happens when the HVAC blows
on that thing how you gonna pay for it
be I wouldn't even know credit cards
personal loans going further into debt
that's how you'd pay for it and we know
cuz that's the calls we get on the show
so that is one option um the other
option is increasing your income now
you've got two kiddos at home what does
Child Care look like with the family
situation um so they do before and after
school so it's about um maybe 250 250 a
month
total okay to cover that and you get
child support monthly typically okay is
that on top of your
income yes okay and no alimony just
child support no correct okay and what
do you do for
work uh I'm a refer referral coordinator
I work in the medical field cool I'm
wondering is there room for uh room for
growth in that medical field so we can
get your income up Ken is already
nodding
yes what kind of work is that I um so I
work remotely from home I uh used to
work as a medical assistant in offices
um so yeah I've always been looking for
a second income actually used to
instacart for a little bit but I end up
stopped doing it because when I went to
go do my taxes the tax person said that
I need to cut that because I'm going to
be jumping into I guess a new tax
bracket and it's not worth it oh no see
this is bad you had a CPA that didn't
understand how tax brackets work yeah
it's like literally this bonehead said
to you don't make more money because
you're going to have to pay more in
taxes I got news for you the more money
you make you're always going to get more
taken out of the check it's just how it
works oh boy need to go back to school
what what does the what does the ladder
look like in your world the typee of
work you do in the medical field what
what would be another rung or two up the
ladder do you
know um I'm not sure I mean I'm
currently in school um because I I
thought I want to do nursing but I end
up that's not what I want to go for so
I'm actually trying to go get my
bachelor in um medical um oh my gosh I
can't even think right now that's okay
I'm trying to become a trying to become
a leader uh get into leadership in the
medical field um like management do you
need a degree for
that uh yes a lot of them are requiring
at least a bachelor okay good how far
area how long before you get that
finished oh a while I just started the
beginning of this year yeah uh how so
let me say this I want to throw it back
to George real quick I I would be okay
with her pausing on that schooling maybe
since she's at the beginning in order to
maybe get financially stable yeah we
need a foundation built and I want to
see what promotion you could get without
the degree
because if we can get more income
whether it's instacart or something else
and I know you got the little ones but
if you can start making more money
ideally getting promoted up the ladder
where you are or inside of another
medical organization and then we get
your debt under control we pay that debt
off you're going to have a massive raise
and now all of a sudden you're going to
have more margin than ever and then we
can tackle school but my concern if I
could play older brother with you just
for a moment M Ian first of all single
mom I my heart goes out to you and
you're an absolute absolute heroine
you're a rock star you're
amazing okay but I don't want you to try
to do too much at the same time and I
think the degree will always be there
and I also know because I've coached
thousands of people on on through
promotions you can get promoted without
a degree can you ultimately get where
you want to go without it I'm trusting
you on this that maybe the answer is no
but the degree will be there I'd rather
you put all your extra time and energy
outside of taking care of those precious
little ones into making more money and
paying off this debt George would you
agree with that absolutely okay so let's
press pause right now on the schooling
because that's money you don't need to
be spending either TR and you're not
paying much in rent it sounds like what
is your rent every month 500 okay well
that's good news so your expenses are
low it sounds like you're bringing in
over three grand a month with this if
you add in the rental income right yes
okay so the question is how much of that
can we to throw at this debt and right
now your baby step one $1,000 starter
emergency fund could you have that in 30
days if you really tried sell some stuff
get on a budget I could great that puts
you at baby step two start to lay out
these debts smallest to largest balance
ignore the interest rates and go what is
that smallest one I'm going to attack it
with a Vengeance while paying minimums
on the rest and financial pieace will
walk you through that you already have
that every dollar the app you just
downloaded that's going to help you
create this margin you can sign up for
that webinar I'm doing we'll show you
how to use it every.com budgeting is the
place to go for that but we want to walk
with you Sharina uh because we believe
that you're going to conquer this debt
you're going to call back and we're
going to do your debt free scream on the
air this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
n
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Ken Coleman our
scripture of the day Luke 9:23 then he
said to them all whoever wants to be my
disciple must deny themselves and take
up their cross daily and follow me Mark
Twain once said the two most important
days in your life are the day you are
born and the day you find out why sounds
like a old school Ken Coleman right
there I like that except it's not it's
Mark Twain hey bonus point if you can
tell me his real name that's his pin
name listen Ken there's enough I got to
keep in my brain what's his real name
just little bonus information for our
audience Samuel Clemens the real real
life name of Mark Twain look at that see
even the audience even the folks in the
lobby like thank you can I appreciate
that just a little I can drop that at my
next cocktail party I was going to say
you're Mark Twain trivia knite yeah or
that I love a trivia knite invite me
folks hey speaking of trivia we uh
people got questions yeah they yeah they
do questions today's question of of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services it's the one place
to find Reliable HVAC plumbing and
electrical providers near you Brands
like airserve Mr Rutter and Mr Electric
have local Pros ready to help so stop
wasting time scrolling through pages of
results just go visit neighbor.com today
by the way my one of my high school
nicknames was Mr Electric but we'll I
was going to guess Mr rder it just
sounds funnier to me it's a funnier
nickname oh man I got to leave that
alone Mr rder Mr rder that's what they
called me uh today's question comes from
Tess in Arizona I'm looking to buy a new
car soon I'm seeing lots of incentives
almost $2,000 off when financing I have
the money saved so what if Oh Boy George
I financed for the discount then paid
off before the first note is due of
course would I be charged interest or
any other fees is this considered debt
genius okay Tess yes this is considered
debt I don't know how you could say I'm
financing and it's not debt now what
you're saying is hey I have the money
what's the big deal I'm just taking I'm
being a smart consumer getting the
discount and then I'll pay it off
immediately well there's some things you
have to consider here number one when
you're financing the dealer can throw in
a lot of different extra fees they tack
on there but they've distracted you
right with this little carrot they've
dangled which is the $2,000 off oh yeah
you can hear it
off we don't know we don't actually know
what a good deal is in this scenario
until you really look at the numbers and
you start and once you're at that point
Ken once you're across the desk in the
financing office the part's over they
know they've got you oh yeah it's a lot
of pressure lot of pressure when you get
in those offices and there could be
prepayment penalties cuz they know
people are going to do this and so they
say hey you can't pay this off within
this time frame and the other thing is
the lender the financing office loses
the commission if you pay it off in a
short window yeah uh so there's a lot of
things there to consider and if you have
the cash I don't know why you're messing
with that I think you're going to get a
better deal and honestly I would run
from that dealership uh it sounds like
you're just seeing this incentive of
online but I would go get a better deal
elsewhere a reputable independent used
car dealer you're going to get a better
car there and when you said new car yeah
I know that's also a big that's a big
trigger for me Ken there's only a few
people who should be buying brand new
cars and that is folks with a million
dollar net worth and no debt yeah
because the hit you're taking on
depreciation is insane yeah new cars
lose 60% of their value in the first 5
years yeah and uh I just did a video on
this K on my YouTube channel of course
you did get this nine days ago and it's
called why is why is no one talking
about America's wealth killer and it has
almost a half million views and people
for once are agreeing with me you're big
time half a million well I think it's
because people this is such a hot IPC
well of course it is yeah it's you know
everybody's driving around the cars you
what else they say well Ken I mean used
cars are as expensive as new cars these
days not true it's wiser to just buy a
new car yeah it's crazy that's insane by
the way you know all this like hubub
about electric cars have you seen the
prices on the electric cars insane now
you bought a used one very yeah mine's
10 years old yeah and by the way it
doesn't look 10 years old thank you I
try to take care of it yeah it looks
fantastic but uh it's it's there's this
there's this pressure and there's going
to be a whole wave of pressure uh to to
buy the electric car it is it is all a
big giant collusion and it's forcing
people to they think well it's where
we're going we got to get one might as
well get it and next thing you know
they're driving around with the $1,500
carpet oh my gosh cuz they're thinking
well one day they're going to force us
to drive first of all there would be an
American Revolt if they forced us all
and I know there's some things in
California going on I can't even count
that as a legitimate State at this point
for all the stuff they're forcing people
to do but in the great state of
Tennessee you drive what you want uh but
with that it's your American right to
drive stupidly expensive cars uh and
they're for your ego don't tell me
they're for reliability and for your
children's safety I just don't buy it
I'm going the other direction folks I'm
I'm going to be driving once I get the
kids everybody's out I've already got
you know I got my classic 72 conver Gia
love that a little air cooled engine I'm
going old school baby and I'm just going
to putt around and put out all kinds of
old emissions just you just take this
emission and shove it you know that's
what I'm going to do old cars you can't
track me because I'm just along in my
little Elon knows where I am at all
times yeah ex's checking he'll pipe
through my car speaker any moment
exactly another reason why I wouldn't
buy an electric car there we go well uh
all that to say Tess I would not do it
for the incentive and financing you're
getting screwed and if you and if you
think you're winning you're definitely
getting screwed because the dealerships
are not losing on these deals AR
whenever they're like well you're really
taking us to the cleaners here my
manager's real upset with me no they
never even talked to the manager they
went to take a smoke break and came back
cuz they knew they got you you what I'm
so glad you brought that up you need to
do a video on YouTube on that like
walking through cuz you're hilarious
what's actually happening when they do
the okay let me go talk to my manager
yeah they're back there talking about
what money they've put on what football
game I'm really going out on a ledge
here for manager docking my pay for this
when I'm not even making a commission
really yeah what a ruse it's always oh
it's exhausting give me a break this is
why I rarely buy cars cuz it's
exhausting when I do I don't deal with
these dealerships no thank you how do
you feel about buying a car directly
from a from a real person that's where I
like to go you know what we're actually
we just filmed a video on this we're
going to release it soon on buying used
cars selling used cars the right way to
do it I think it's great now do your due
diligence don't buy a used car from a
random Joe Schmo and then yell at us
when it's a clunker get an inspection
yeah you can go to Firestone get this
done for 50 bucks it'll do 120 point
inspection the other thing to do is
actually check the Carfax check the
history make sure it has a clean title
meet them at the at a police station
meet them at the bank do your due
diligence when it comes to these things
but once you do the the police station
yeah that's a great place to meet for
any
transaction I mean it is but that seems
like a little much I think the grocery
store is fine well you know in your
neighborhood Ken but my seedy
neighborhood no it's fine but yeah bring
a friend along do what you got to do
that's good that's very practical
information should we I don't think we
have time for another question Ken I'm
sorry Diane we love you we'll get you on
the next one go well uh it's risky you
know what we'll do we'll get her to
we'll kick her to Ken show does that
work yeah okay all right we'll do that
Diane we'll we'll take you on the Ken
Coleman show Christian I'll make sure we
get to you sorry I I but you know I got
excited about cars well listen we see
Tik Tok videos
we've played it on the show before where
people are bragging about having a
combined $2,000 plus dollars of car
payments two people in a f where you
know they're probably making a combined
60 70 grand and they're car a new level
of stupidity when you're bragging about
how stupid your decision was yeah but
but you know why they don't think it's
stupid because we've been told that
having a nice car is a right it is if
you're an American you have the right to
go down to uh Billy Bob's truck in pora
and get yourself a truck that cost
$80,000 and I'm probably low price I'm
probably the last stat I checked it was
15% of folks with car payments have a
payment over $1,000 for one car is that
did you hear that that I I got to tell
you I need some mails that's almost one
out of five people walking around with
over a thousand bucks in a car payment
and then the same people can who are
like man This president's really killing
us with inflation these grocery prices
are really crushing us man right and I'm
going dude you drive a car with A500 car
payment right I can help you with
inflation stop spending your money on
stupid stuff you bonee head there it is
that's how I want to end Today's show it
feels appropriate well Ken it's been fun
always enjoy hosting with you thank you
for listening America thanks to all the
folks in the booth Christian will James
Zach Andrew keeping the show afloat for
us today we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime spend wisely
save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started